[Music]
whichever you on tinder what about you
oh I'm on match.com but I'm gonna check
OkCupid to check out Kelly look at that
smile
Kelly did you lead a guy actually I
stopped looking because now I have an
attorney kitty
introducing attorney Peter the first
genetically engineered cat designed to
live more than a hundred years it's a
revolution in man replacement technology
specially bred to kill spiders rub your
feet perform simple home repairs listen
to your day and drink as much red wine
as you do as long as you're alive it
turn a kitty
you won't die alone great but what about
sex and raising a family Eterna kitty
can't have sex with you or give you
children
you need a tourniquet e 2.0 the only cat
man hybrid legally available in North
America attorney Kitty 2.0 has all the
features of the original aterna Kitty
Plus fully functional genitals to
provide years of intense physical
satisfaction you turn a kitty 2.0 who
needs a man
[Music]
[Applause]
good for the kitty hey thanks for
watching please subscribe to my youtube
channel so they will stop making me
shoot these videos please